okay hello everyone welcome to another
design review as part of our version 14
season of design reviews
we are looking at our question framework
and
Let's uh take a look here
all right
so
partial credit
right so this is something that's been
in for
a couple versions
where
if you have if the student so this the
student's answer is that three one two
list and if that is a list and you say
element-wise assessment is true then
each element gets assessed on its own
and the total assessment Can it can do
partial credit and it kind of combines
the scores sort of thing linearly by
default linearly we have all sorts of
advanced options for customizing it okay
um
but that doesn't support
common questions that we want to support
for other cases where the student's
answer is a list
um
right so the example right below you
know find the roots of the polynomials
there's four roots they need to give
them all
if we use the element-wise assessment
you could just give a subset
and that's you know more usually you
want that it wanted to be an all or
nothing not a partial credit situation
in this case
right
so wait a second I'm sorry the
I'm sorry you want them to give all of
them but they can be in any order yes so
the teacher wants to yeah exactly the
teacher wants them to give all of them
in any order
and they don't want to have to write
their own comparison function formula
okay so we just need a thing well it
just says allow any order right right
right so that's what we're doing so
we've named it list interpretation let's
see the next one down in the light blue
that's a crazy name I mean I won't be
happy to rename it
incomprehensible name right so it's uh
if the student gives a list
how should it be assessed is what it's
saying yeah
list assessment might be better
um that's one of the
wonderful ideas so what are the other
right hand sides so if you scroll down a
little bit I have some pseudo
documentation here
okay
right so we've elementalized assessment
used to be the the key and it took a
Boolean value now it's the right hand
side to this new Option and it'll be
Backward Compatible but we'll change
your documentation to the new thing
okay
um
okay let me see
uh
so
look we can't be inconsistent order list
unordered I mean
uh
okay
what other things do we have in the in
this assessment function options in that
Association
right so
um
right so you can give like a custom
function instead of using both those
names of these things like comparator
selector
okay
um yeah that the score combiner and
answer correct combiner those are things
I was alluding to earlier where you can
instead of just totaling up the partial
credit you can have a custom thing okay
look I suggest we call it like
list handling or something
and then we say
um
and then it's like something like
orderless
ordered
well traders orderless in order to also
element wise so
if we're going to change your name we
might as well change it significantly to
well wait wait wait what do you mean
there also element wise so the
assessment function is applied to the
elements of the list as opposed to when
it's none the assessment function is
applied to the full list okay well so I
think then that
those should be two different options
because you're either applying it to the
whole list so
I mean basically it's listability
right
in some sense yeah it's analogous I
would say I guess you know if it's
well okay so
I mean
so the case the default case
I mean so then the other ones might be
element wise
ordered
element wise orderless
and now is there another case
um
you've got three cases up there
otherwise assessment right right so okay
so the the other
tricky part of this so
uh so it's comparing the how we've done
ordered uh
ordered lesson under the list how we
haven't implemented now the answer key
the values of the answer key are lists
right so it will
make sure that the values in the
student's answer
correspond to the complete teacher list
no that's not what you just told me you
just told me it was element wise yes but
they're compared element-wise so if you
do if your comparison method is you know
a calculus then it's going to use the
calculus comparison method to look at
one element of the student to one
element of the teacher does the student
have to have the same number of elements
as yes yes that in in these new methods
it does except for the element wise one
otherwise assessment is different yes
that's why it's different in that case
typically the the answer key is not a
list
right the values in the answer key are
not a list because it's only
it's doing each one yeah
so I understand why audit isn't the
default
what's the difference between the whole
thing and ordered well the whole thing
the assessment function that like the
internal assessment function gets past
the entire list
so
you can imagine treating it like you
know uh
a vector right
um
oh yeah explain this again so it's
instructed to consider the case where
you had some tolerance right
so if you if there's tolerance in here
and you were looking at the whole if you
had none what we're calling none so far
then the tolerance would be like the
norm of the differences between the
vectors okay does that make sense right
the whole things are being passed to the
comparator
whereas if you had tolerance and you
said what we currently call list
interpretation goes to ordered list then
the tolerance would be applied to each
element so each element in the student's
answer needs to be with intolerance of a
distinct answer in the teacher's key
um
I mean I doubt this is all the cases
so this is yeah there could be more in
the future but this covers like
the Wolfram problem generator question
set okay so let's just understand this
one here so this one here
is it has to be all the elements
and they have to be in the same order as
in the key
but the comparator is applied one by one
no I don't understand why both of those
so whole list
you say can't be orderless
yeah okay
so
this here
they might have a different number of
elements
correct
uh separate elements I'm not sure that's
element-wise that's what you were
calling element-wise okay
yes they might have a different length a
different yes
right
I like to think of this like you know
name as many vice presidents as you can
yeah okay
let me think about this come on you guys
can do better than this come on this is
a model
how about anybody else speak up
I mean you've been thinking about this
for a while I'm coming into this cold so
I agree I agree I agree yeah
um
I mean I I thought putting them all on
the same
property made sense well fine but let's
then
partial
um well element-wise look look look look
look I mean
I mean what do you have the line above
that seems perfectly reasonable I don't
like it I I mean whole list is the same
as what we were calling none yeah that's
right um that makes sense to me I mean
okay so hold on this is
okay we could even call separate
elements partial credit no
um
well I mean the obvious there will be
some elements but that's rather silly
uh
any
I think that suggests there are very few
I mean
it's like you you can have as many as
you want
uh
we could just call it element wise
no yeah there's a function called
contains any right is there an analogy
there like all those contains this
contains that
yes but but here it's Counting
so maybe differently maybe maybe we say
count elements
count any
no but what about this because it is
counting and the other ones are not
counting
do you see what I'm saying
thank you
but I don't know if that count helmets
well but you that's what you're doing
right the the score is the count of
agreeing elements correct
right well
what other words
what's that it's the total of the score
of the agreeing elements
I mean that's kind of say what they're
doing I mean that's that's an accurate
name it's just a little long I don't
it's fine
I think it's better to have it long and
accurate than to be incomprehensible
all right that's what I suggest
yeah there's a type I want all elements
orderless yeah
okay should we move on yep
so that yeah we had in the lat in 133 we
had uh arithmetic result polynomial
result and calculus result we're adding
algebra result
um that's the previous subsection I
don't know if you care to look at that
it's pretty consistent
so tell me what class this will be
useful for algebra
like you know okay so the the calculus
one is useful for Calculus class the
algebra one is useful for an algebra
class that's the idea
okay
right okay either quintessential problem
for this is you know yeah here's the
polynomial cell for x
um
and
right and it
allows so the student can you know it
this it allows evaluations in this
answer that are don't contain things
like cells right
so so you could say they could say in
this case 4 over a plus b plus 4 over a
plus b exactly and that'll be more
correct because it isn't doesn't differ
by algebra it only differs by arithmetic
okay
um so that's the idea
what about a squared minus B squared
divided by a plus B versus a minus B
that would work too
right so just can't have things like
solve reduced fine instance but I mean
it's not really what people want
but I mean
you know that a squared minus B squared
I mean there are things which
what the heck
okay
and now I say God would say just
together of that
see what I'm saying so which functions
does it do and which does it not do
because I think that one many people
would not Mark that as a correct answer
I would think I mean I'm far away from
that world but I would think that would
not be considered the right answer if
this is what they're looking for right
so if it doesn't contain a symbol under
Blacklist it basically does equal you
know double equals and wraps it in
simplify and if it's true it gets marked
true
to me this would not be the right answer
this thing up here yet if I go this
you know double equals a minus B and I
say simplify I'm pretty certain that
that will say true yeah right okay so I
don't think that's I I I don't think
that's right I mean I think that that
perhaps
there are certain set of functions it
doesn't simplify have options for which
functions it can use
I don't think so it takes assumptions
but I don't think it takes
I don't know well I think it does take
methods I think it does take some method
options okay
now transformation functions oh okay
you've got to ask somebody who teaches
this stuff I don't have the slightest
idea okay I just don't think this is
right
I'm not making sense
who have you asked to actually teach you
this stuff
well we have the edtech group and we've
talked to them
um so I don't know how many of them have
some middle school math teaching yeah we
need somebody with specificity to tell
us what they would do in this case use
this case as an example what would they
do what would they expect I mean we have
comparison methods that would prevent
that both I understand myself I want to
know what whether this one which you're
proposing is the default algebra classes
is right
okay
I don't know I mean you're asking me
okay I simply don't know and I know that
I don't know so you've got to ask
somebody who does okay
do we have to can we get no you got to
do that offline yeah yeah we yeah we
don't need to do it this way
okay
I mean one thing I want to say is that I
do think that
these comparisons have got to be fairly
stable
I mean we can't say are we just changed
a version and then somebody goes back
and re-marks exam papers from two years
ago and all the scores change
do you understand what I'm saying yes
so there's a certain argument that we
should make sure there's versioning
information in these um in these
comparators
am I making sense
yeah again you want to ask somebody
who's more of an expert on how this
works on the ground in the field Etc but
my feeling is that we want something
where it's like algebra and it's like
version you know comparison you know
assessment version Arrow 14.0 or
something like this
do you see what I'm saying yeah
I mean do you think we should just name
these things like algebra result 13 zero
I don't think we should I think we
should we should have a separate thing
for versions because some people will be
kind of sloppy I mean look if people if
this is
for
you know it's part of the documentation
and part of the the things we have to
train people who are using these for
like high stakes exams et cetera Etc
because there's no you know if it's an
intermediate look what do I know about
this stuff but my impression is if it's
an intermediate thing in some class
and you know in different years it works
differently
it's fine
to get what I'm saying if it
progressively works better because we're
more sophisticated finer grained control
Etc et cetera nobody's going to object
the thing the scenario that I'm
concerned about is that there was an
exam that was done and somebody tries to
rescore the exam and they get different
results
yeah I understand I don't know how
important that effect is okay I don't
know maybe people I I don't know how
long they even keep the exam
documentation
maybe they probably throw it away after
some period of time I just don't know
make sense yes so you've got to have
somebody who is actually an expert in
how these things are used on the ground
right and there's people in the you know
uh
you know edtech group who do know this
stuff who probably should have been in
this meeting
okay but I'm telling you my my version
of this I I think you need to look more
carefully at this I mean can we go live
with something like this probably yes we
didn't have this before so people are
not going to immediately pour it into
lots of things
I mean it probably should be
experimental
oh it's experimental sure
okay you may also want to uh field
tested with actual students as opposed
to not just teachers not just you know
like have people
you know
algebra's High School level right so you
want to have maybe some high school
level students try this out and give you
feedback
through people who are actually dealing
with the on the ground deployment okay
which includes things like that
but you know we're we're designing this
in a very theoretical way here
foreign
so the next thing here is a feature that
we do know is important for people in
the Attic group and that's
you know uh Advanced tolerance support
okay
so we have two different new math
comparisons that support Advanced
tolerance
that uh
one of them this one that we've so far
called numerical approximation just adds
tolerance to each numeric value in the
teachers and in the T in the answer key
and the next one that we call the
engineering result only adds it to
you know uh inexact values
in the answer key
okay
oh come on
actually
okay I understand
um
what's it going to do by default
presumably it's going to use Precision
control but how does it know what the
Precision that's being asked for
what the hell the tolerance oh that
that's going away that's an
implementation uh transient thing it's
not going to be real okay but there's a
tolerance number that's going to be
given there's no tolerance number that's
going to be given and that number
might not be applied to exact numbers
right
that number that engineering result it
will not be applied I understand I
understand so that's what I'm saying is
that the the choice is you know now
normally
when we have a tolerance for equal
simply if it's an integer if it's an
exact integer
um
then
you know there's no tolerance ever
right what's the case one one point
double equals one gives true right
there's a there's a
uh Precision I know but I understand why
in this case here they don't give the
comparator as
or the the thing that they're comparing
to as an exact numbers and make it so
that whenever there's an exact number
well that's going through fit which
automatically numericizes things
that's why that one all right
it's there
okay but but I don't understand I I'm
just saying there's an answer right
right that that is supposed to be the
right answer if that right answer
is numerical then do a numerical
comparison if that right answer is exact
then do an exact comparison
and that seems to be much more intuitive
than some weird option that decides
whether to do this and then just say the
rule is if it's exact it's an exact
comparison if it's an exact it's not
yeah actually it's what it's doing
in the first method
uh so yeah yeah I understand but I'm
saying why isn't that just the way it
works
I don't understand what you're proposing
it so I suppose in getting rid of these
options and I'm proposing simply telling
people if you want it to do an exact
comparison don't say the answer is one
say the answer is one point
how do you say what the tolerance should
be
I'll have a tolerance option
but the tolerance option only applies to
inexact numbers right well we can't use
the tolerance option with some of the
other methods it just we don't have a
way to implement it with everything I'm
sorry which other methods
the we can't do it with anything that is
going through equal we can only do it
with things that are going through match
which so calculus result and algebra
result would not support it
I don't think anybody wants an exact
algebra and calculus results
I don't think anybody wants them
right but we need
we need I think it's interesting that we
need name comparison methods that
support but look in the algebra and
calculus case if somebody gives in exact
numbers we should just do what equal
does because it's a corner case
but when I think of it tolerance
of Tolerance what is it the teacher if
the teacher says
well I think it's not something they're
going to do so I'm not worried about it
I mean in other words if they give if
they say if you type x minus one point
and if you type x minus one point
you know I just I just don't believe it
I don't think it's a case we need to
worry about you know one point this well
Market is Right forget it no they don't
need it
we definitely want to have this where
you can specify exactly where the
tolerance is on values but no you don't
not for algebra
okay but there are problems where we
want it absolutely numerical problems
not algebra problems right so we need a
name we need a name for the comparison
method that accepts tolerance for
something like an engineering problem
okay but I don't understand why we're
not just saying tolerance Arrow whatever
a number that is what we're saying yeah
that that is just that is the transient
thing that real won't actually be in
there okay so the tolerance then will
probably be something like
uh you know I don't know whether it's
you know significant digits I mean
there's there's any one of these things
it matters whether we're talking about
significant digits or absolute or
whatever yes right now it's all absolute
but we also we also have uh are going to
support scaled for relative uh but we're
not doing significant digits you know we
used to always talk about when we're
doing designs it's like a boat
and it's taking on water
and you start running the pumps because
more and more things are like oh my gosh
we got this issue we've got that issue
run the pumps faster
there's not the right way to do this
I mean in you know possibly the right
thing to do is you know what what if
you've got three numbers and one of them
is supposed to be this tolerance and one
is supposed to be that tolerance we have
that right the discussion point at the
very bottom of the notebook right now
yeah okay well how is that supposed to
work so you there you would mark up
individual values with a wrapper
and all this will be written through the
authoring notebook where which nobody's
going to understand by the time this is
being written that nobody's going to
understand it
all right so look let's talk about
what's actually needed here okay it does
matter whether they get you know 18.23
which how many digits do they supposed
to get
right let's say that the answer is
supposed to be 18.23 meters per second
what happens if it's in different units
do we deal with that
what happens if they say centimeters per
hour right so if the answer is a
quantity we have good support for units
in the quantity comparison method we
have a comparison mythical quantity okay
works on units and it already takes a
tolerance it's an ambiguous but when the
answer is a Formula what does the
tolerance mean it's the tolerance given
units the tolerance is given in units
okay it's absolutely so it's an absolute
total the conversion works on yes
okay let me point out that a randomly
generated problem absolute tolerance may
not work
I understand yes okay
that's the most common thing in just a
naked number on the right hand side of
the tolerance option should mean
absolute
yeah although I think
you know significant digits I.E
precision
is an even more common thing
get it right to X number of significant
figures again I don't think anybody who
has ever taken a question a quiz were
they well what do they say I mean they
say you know within you know within X
get the value you know within this many
and they mean an absolute thing really
well I mean I'm out of this game because
I've never taken a multiple choice
like
yeah it was a thing when I was a kid
wasn't yet a thing so multiple choice
wasn't the other thing
um I guess they do say Express to so
many significant digits that's that
there's certainly do we have anybody
from northern Alpha Team here
I think we just have the wrong people
for this meeting
because we need people who've actually
you know who are actually doing this
stuff on the ground
because I don't know what the right
thing to do is here
we can ask them outside of this meeting
we can yeah we can continue this with a
larger group and yeah I think that's
what we have to do I just don't know and
what I would do in the first instance is
if it's exact make it exact if it's
inexact use the tolerance but I don't
know how you do that when there are a
list of numbers and some of them are a
.01 and some of them are a thousand how
do you use a tolerance then if you've
got a list of numbers with very
different magnitudes right
so what do you do
well we I mean one thing we've we've
supported Within These like engineering
result what we're calling engineering
yourself numerical approximations you
can do tolerance because it's a scaled
of you know oh that's horrifying that's
absolutely horrifying what's wrong with
working Precision that's what we use
everywhere else
or something like that I mean that's a
little bit different that's a little bit
different right that's the Precision the
computation should be having it not how
things should be compared right so it's
a comparison Precision but that's
something we don't have right we have
that in equal or something like equal no
there's no as far as I know equal is
hard set to like a machine precision
I mean you need help if this is done on
a test the students would be calculators
right I mean this is like this would be
deployed as a web page or something is
that right that I guess a homework
problem yes and as far as I know all
high school students in the entire world
still you know use calculators for this
sort of stuff
so that means that you know like the 0.5
meter per second tolerance is you know
that's probably way too big right like a
calculator could get this right but you
know four or five six digits of
precision and that's probably you know
expected like it should at least
calculated usage has been declining
largely as a result of the world from
Alpha and related things so just for
what it's worth yeah I mean my students
still use calculators either on the
phone or an actual calculator when
they're doing algebra and this sort of
you know physics problems so yeah okay
um
so if if the problem is given with like
you know 18.23 then I suspect that the
answer also has to have at least you
know those two digits of precision and
maybe you know one less or one extra
item down but I don't think it would
explicitly state that 0.5 meter per
second thing in any printer what you're
saying is before the digits if they give
if the teacher gives the answer is 18.23
they're expecting that the actual
results given will lie so is 18.22 an
acceptable result or not
well no because that's not the answer
right the answer will be something like
you know 25 I don't know what the
question I try to understand the
question I don't even understand the
question but let's not worry about it
suppose the answer is you know
512.18 or something right like that
that's
I imagine that
you know the answer will want to be with
some you know okay what I think we
should do I mean the question we're
sorry the types of questions we're
considering here is where the answer is
512.83 times X plus a
over five right you know that's that's a
weird Corner case but I mean the case
we're just a number isn't complicated
right we have had that yes it is
complicated yes it is complicated to do
it right
it's a bad way to do it it's fine if you
have a single number if you have a
vector for example and the vector is
this right it's a bad way to do it right
so on vectors we do the norm of the
difference oh for goodness sake and no
teacher is going to know to compute to
specify the tolerance for the norm of
the difference you know if they're
saying the comparison method is Vector
then what
element wise they think it's element
wise what is the comparator because they
say I want the kids to get it right to
within you know
you see what I'm saying right right then
what we've had for a couple of versions
is just absolute
so don't we have a round for that or
whatever we do we do but okay no
teachers we will really know this it's
Michael because this is the whole
Michael and Jose are the ones who are
really going to know this this is subtle
this is not something where we're just
going to hack it through a round is not
part of the solution I don't think at
all well I'm not certain about that I'm
not certain I think I think we could
imagine a solution for very Persnickety
teachers were they given around
specification oral interval
specifications and they want the student
to be within a certain number of
standard deviations if possible or no
they want them to be within the plus
minus in the around it's not a plus
minus it's a normal distribution I'm
aware I know yeah I know so it's a way
it's an alternative to giving an
interval which is a it's a more
convenient way to specify something like
an interval but it it is a normal
distribution rate I'm well aware I know
so the question is okay maybe around
just a wrong thing but like there's
other things right like I don't think
that okay there's interval and standard
interval and so on right that certainly
versus Persnickety okay but again Jose
has worked on precisely this for a round
Etc et cetera et cetera let's get him
involved in this okay that's just not
you know break this for you know the
whole generation but the computer
science is doing this in a sloppy way
design might not be the education center
I don't care I don't care so let's get
in this meeting people who actually
understand the math of this and the
people who understand how it's used in
education and we have neither of those
groups here so we really can't do this
in this meeting
sorry
this is going to be subtle and we're
going to end up with probably several
options and it's going to be quite
subtle
and we're going to end up with some
reasonable default that people will use
and that will do the right thing most of
the time
and a teacher wouldn't necessarily need
to know the future
right and my guess is that a very
important piece of information in the
default is what the teacher typed as the
answer
of course yeah yes but the teacher might
have typed this as the answer and what
does that mean how much Precision does
that have
see what I'm saying because that has
that amount of precision
right okay so this is quite subtle right
in other words when they say n of 1 7 do
they mean uh six digits do they mean 16
digits what do they mean
see what I'm saying
so let's
I you know I'm a framework we need
another meeting for the with the right
set of people here for this
sorry
I mean again I would recommend that you
meet with these people separately I'm
I'm telling you with Ed tech people all
the time okay but I think you need
Michael and Jose as well I think you
need those people I think this is subtle
I think again
Michael knows all these things that come
from all the standards that nist and so
on have put out about what significant
figures actually mean let's use all that
information and all of that tradition so
to speak here
okay and not kind of hack it with some
random thing
it is subtle and and there will be
Corner cases
now again people will use the default 99
of the time so let's get the defaults as
right as we can and the number one piece
of information is what did the teacher
say the answer was
am I making sense yes
and you know in in the most complicated
I mean I think equal this is all built
into equal and that is what the default
is
okay
well let's ask these guys because I'm
not certain that's all that's the way
everything works if that's the default
then we don't have to have this
discussion the only discussion that we
have is does one point mean the same as
one
no that's not the only discussion well
no in that case where we're just saying
we use the implied Precision is not the
only thing teachers are going to want
okay well what position are they going
to want and how they're going to want to
specify tolerance
no they're not no they're not not in the
only if it's a single number if it's a
single number they want to specify how
do you think they think about it
how do you think they're going to think
about it if the answer is 18.23 how are
they going to think about what the
student could enter they're going to
think about it in terms of the
characters the student types I think
yep they are well I'm thinking to think
about in terms of the math in other
words if the student enters they're
gonna think I want the student to put in
two digits which they're going to think
means a hundredth so they're going to
want to put a hundredth somewhere
they're not going to want to put in two
well no the question is because they're
not going to think about it some
teachers would say this is not the right
answer that's too much precision
I would say that you would say that yes
yes but I don't think that's
well let's find out we don't know I
think a lot of people if they don't
currently mark this as wrong they should
yeah yeah I I okay I don't know either
but I think students know how to round
you know a digit like the last you know
like well actually I've seen lots of
examples where they quote calculator
where they copy every single digit from
the display of a calculator
yeah yeah but but like if it's just
wrong if the problem asks for you know
like give two digits after the decimal
point they should know
the answer should not be give something
like this but default by default if the
if the input contains numbers to two
digit Precision they should not give
this by default even if their calculator
or you know wolfen language said that
am I making sense
yes
I consider it the wrong answer and that
to me is something where you know we
will need an option that determines
whether you think that's the wrong
answer or not
okay I'm telling you this is subtle
let's try to get it right
okay
I know it's a live stream James is
asking is there a negative marking
function
in other words if you say this you get
minus yeah yes that's been in for the
long one yeah and the first option to
assessment function you can give an
arbitrary number of values that are
compared against and each one can have
be correct or incorrect and give an
arbitrary score so you could say one is
negative one point or negative 10 points
and so on let me just make a comment
about a generalized comment here I mean
the vast majority of people who are
building edtech software don't have a
clue about all of these issues all these
subtle issues about numerical analysis
and so on we do have a clue let's not
get it wrong
that's a good point it is our
Yeah we actually have a bunch of world
experts in this so let's not not use
them
to do the best we can to get this right
it's a good point
okay so we need to come back to this but
you should do a separate meeting first
and then we'll come back to this
okay and you know I'm telling you it's
subtle and I think we're going to want
to have things like standard interval
numbers we've got you know some people
who are doing some very fancy you know
high stakes exam might well want to
actually write in sent an interval type
things
but people who are just sort of oh I you
know I think the answer is 18.2 or
something just give that and Etc et
cetera Etc
okay all right so this next part we can
do if you want it's not um
uh well I if you had run anything else
previously in the notebook it would have
loaded the packlet and you could run it
so
well
no no no just run any where it says
question or just do question object
um
all right so this is very much not
design review stage
that should have floated you did the
backlink install on the top right
yeah I did yeah okay well I mean I do
this one then
ouch this is
great
yeah I'm number one yes yeah maybe
there's a problem with I can I'm happy
to demo it if you want
if you grab it directly from me uh no it
won't let me until you give it up
foreign
rebuilt uh question authoring notebook
it's what the heck is the highlight
color light blue this is that design has
not
gone to how to pass at this at all so
okay so the main thing that I want to
show here is the
complete change in ux so instead of
having like an area here with a bunch of
input fields that had a whole bunch of
complications to it what if you want a
GUI editing thing for a specific
question you hit this and it opens a
secondary dedicated notebook just for
one question
and if you know and you fill it out
and uh and then when you're done you can
test it within this notebook you can
tweak it you can add random variables
make it a question generated it's a good
idea and then when you're done you hit
finished
and it
this is a little slow now but it
collapses back into here
and if you want saved of course it's
just stored in this notebook so you
would want to save this Untitled 60 to
save it okay
to do that you can if you hit this
button again it'll open it again and you
can go back and forth Okay add infinite
and then we have this Toggler here which
I made up this icon it's not right
um to switch to code mode so if you want
to just write the code it's infinitely
customized it's an improvement over
overbuilt and then you hit the toggle
again and it opens the notebook again
and you can keep going
okay right so and you can you know
there's tools for markings you know this
a is is you know going to be filled in
by uh as a slot uh it's not literally a
sort of thing that so how did you make
that slot
it's an inline cell
is that what you mean
yo how did you type it right now I
wasn't playing it oh I hit this button I
highlighted it and I hit this button in
the middle bar so what does that button
say it says select for formatting which
isn't great I don't know in in the the
in Danny's version of this that inspired
it it was called something something
with math in the name I didn't love that
either it means
then it'll be formatted
um
it'll in the collection object it'll
it'll helpful I think it's Computing a
random variable to put it well it both
it does both
um so because it formats it shows the
value right
I mean that's basically just like in a
template notebook if you start a new
template notebook there's a thing
exactly like that
okay
I think it's just an expression template
expression right it's it's the thing
right
right that evaluates that we could use
the same visual another metaphor there
okay
right because that's going to be
evaluated on
notebook load in the case of template
notebooks
and this is the second one will be
instantiated in the same way right it's
yeah I I I'm not defending these terms
um yeah we could certainly call it
something like template template
expression
something like that yeah templates
version might make sense yeah
um and then when like it so we have
these that map to comparison methods
um where you know I don't know by the
way where the template slot will be
useful for these things
I don't know I mean I can imagine
something where
if the person's name is Bill give them
this and if it's Bob give them that
right I mean you're gonna need to write
code in that case for sure
um yeah I mean maybe it's a silly case
but I mean I could imagine
yeah it's a silly case right and you can
use the same you know you can use the
same
um tools in the answers I like that
makes more sense when this is multiple
choice sorry this isn't multiple choice
so like if it's if it's a multiple
choice answer definitely
um
I don't know why this didn't turn gold
it should have turned gold there's still
bugs
um but okay yeah so then you know you
some of these have more options you know
you can get more fine-grained well each
one should have some kind of a mouse
over but I mean that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah we need more info buttons we need
tool tips we need lots of stuff
um I I know I was really well I like the
job 14-0 but it's just not going to make
it in time for the freeze because
there's a lot to do and I just wanted to
sort of show the general ux of the
secondary notebook that's toggle yeah I
like it I think this is good it's a
great great Improvement I think it uses
the learnings that we have from things
like the function repository that you
know it's going to look easy when you
start typing something or nobody will
ever start and it's all implemented on
that same definition of the client that
we're using for the resource yeah
good stuff okay great if you think this
is the right direction I think it is
certainly plow ahead without really any
other comment okay the other thing that
those
um numerical Precision things those
we've got to um uh yeah okay we should
wrap up here all right
um but you you will you will iterate on
that okay thanks yes we will okay thank
you bye bye